in 1989 five black and Latino teenagers
were wrongly accused of the brutal rape
of a jogger in New York City's Central
Park
Antron McCray Kevin Richardson Yusef
Salaam Raymond Santana and Korey wise
became known as a Central Park five they
alleged that police coerced them into
making false confessions the boys were
charged and convicted with no physical
evidence implicating them think about
that for a second they spent six to 13
years in prison but in 2002 their
convictions were overturned after DNA
evidence and a confession exonerated
them now Academy Award nominee Ava
Duvernay is telling their story in her
four-part series when they see us you
tell the truth we clear things up we
send you home okay yes sir great Kevin
Richardson said you raped a lady in the
park and a voodoo Verna is with us good
morning welcome thank you this is a
riveting show let's just start with the
title because originally you wanted to
call it Central Park five I think
originally people assumed that it would
be called Central Park five there's a
documentary called that and this is what
the boys were called for me I was really
interested in getting underneath this
moniker that had been given to them by
the police by the prosecutors by the
press and really to humanize these boys
and ask you to see them not just the
label they've been given well I thought
I knew everything about this story
because I remember when it happened and
I remember very vividly and recently I
got to meet all five of them at the
Innocence Project and Ava I actually
went to them and apologized because I
was embarrassed and ashamed because I
believed everything about that storing
hook line and sinker it never occurred
to me that they could possibly be
innocent and I think watching your piece
I learned things that I didn't know but
what you did was you really did show
like you put humanity you made us see
them in a different light and I didn't
know that that was possible considering
what we'd been told about this well
maybe
that night was was was important for
them just for people to see and hear
their story they said a lot of people
come up to the La Jolla job that's right
that's right and so I think it asks us
as as the public to really interrogate
the stories that we're hearing through
the news yeah you all have a certain
responsibility but we as the public have
a responsibility to ask the next
question to really interrogate what we
believe and enough people didn't do that
at this time so hopefully the film
allows people to think again and do I
have this right you started on this
project because of a tweet at you asking
you to tell the story I get a lot of
tweets yeah you do a lot of tweets but
this one I was always riveted by this
case at the time that these boys were
teenagers in Harlem I was a teenager
grew up in Compton on it on the opposite
coast you know I was always connected to
the story and was riveted by what they
were my age my age and just seeing them
and me and my friends um I was really
connected to when you think of that
tweet and the the journey you've been on
from that tweet to being in a theater
watching it with them watching them
watch themselves what was it like you
know I've had a lot of beautiful things
have in my career but there was nothing
like sitting behind them those five men
in a small screening room watching them
watch a story we spent four years to
make they wept I wept they cheered they
held hands it was what were they crying
for what did they see
and I saw each other they had been so
into their own story and experience yeah
to finally understand with all the other
families and and their brothers the
other men were going through yeah was
something that really was a revelation
for them well so Pat one of the things
that's so powerful about this is it's
not just what they went through it's
what their families oh yeah the parents
so true what was the tweet you saw that
caught your eye because as you point out
you get a lot of tweets they tweeted me
Raymond Santana tweeted me that said one
central part five yeah
Ava what is your next film after Selma
sepia I have a question one question
mark and then hashtag fingers crossed
guess it works Oh IDM Tim slid into his
doom and I said hey I'm coming into New
York in a few months maybe we can get
together so they were awarded a big
settlement years later however their
lives changed but they still have never
gotten an official apology for never
received an apology in the city
guilty there's nine zero no no they
didn't at all
you know money can't buy back your youth
yeah money can't bring back fractured
families as you continue to watch the
piece you really see the effective of
this this ordeal this incarceration on
the family family structures broke
broken apart no amount of money can get
that back so they're they're making
their way through you know it's a 30
year old story but it sometimes seems
like everything old is new again and I
was struck by the fact that President
Trump then as a private citizen actually
took out an ad in the aftermath of the
boys you know better than me $85,000
yeah sure did has the president ever
commented on that as he they never got
an apology from the city or from the
prosecutors he ever heard from the
president on that have I heard have you
are you aware of him saying anything cuz
I'm not I think he made some kind of
snide tweet sometime last year and it
brings me to the second question which
is worth 30 years on some things have
changed something some things have
improved can this kind of thing happen
again
oh yeah we happen now oh can absolutely
happen now the question is can we
interrogate what's happened in the past
to safeguard ourselves from it happening
in the future that's why I'm such a
student of history I like to embed
historical context in my work we can
only be kind of better the situation if
we realize the details of what happens
so that's what we invite people to check
out well tonight is your big premiere
whether you're here on our first day
thank you thank you good to see you when
when they see us premieres next Friday
that's may 31st on Netflix